- What's up, guys, we're back in the lab
with an experiment you were
told never to try at home.
Today we're experimenting with water
and high voltage electricity.
Now we're told all the time
never to get electricity
even close to water, but why?
What exactly would
happen, if we accidentally
dipped electrical cables
into a glass of water?
The purpose of this video
today is to find out.
Now, for our first experiment,
I've rigged up this very unsafe device,
which basically takes the
electrical power out of my house
and splits it into these two wires.
If I touch these two wires together now,
you can see the light flickers behind me.
When they're disconnected,
the light is off,
but if the wires touch,
the light turns back on.
Now for this first test,
I've filled up this glass
with distilled water.
Now, distilled water has nothing in it.
It should be pure and non-conductive,
meaning electricity should not
be able to flow through it.
Let's see if that's really the case.
Here we go.
(funky pop music)
Absolutely nothing.
So, you can see that both
wires are completely submerged
in the water here and nothing
is happening to the light.
It's not even flickering,
but let's try touching the
wires underneath the water
and see what happens.
(pinging)
Wow, it made this little pop
and I saw a little flash of electricity
and the light turned on behind me.
(pinging)
It's actually pretty cool
and I can see little bubbles
coming off the electrodes.
It makes me wonder if those
are little hydrogen bubbles.
I think we've got a little mini
electrolysis generator here.
So update, guys, we have confirmed
that distilled water is non-conductive.
We had absolutely no reaction.
So I've gone ahead and filled our glass up
with tap water now to see
if there's any difference.
Electricity versus tap water, here we go.
(funky pop music)
Oh, interesting, look at that.
It looks like the light is
actually turning on a little bit.
It's not like brightening right up,
but they're definitely
is some electrical flow.
If I pull the wires further
apart, it gets dimmer
and if I bring them closer together,
it gets a little bit brighter.
That is interesting.
Look at that, if I move the wires,
the light kind of flickers
and these wires aren't touching,
they're just submerged
in the water itself.
So apparently, tap water
is slightly conductive.
I mean, it won't run the
full current through it,
but you can see there definitely
is some kind of electrical connection,
because these wires are not touching
and of course, if you
touch the wires together,
then it goes to full bright.
That's amazing.
So, obviously we're not
getting the full current flow
through the water, but
we are getting something.
That's very interesting.
Now, I think the original concerns
of electricity mixing with water
stem back to when people
had portable heaters
falling into their bathtub,
or dropping their
hairdryer into the bathtub.
We have to remember that
bathtubs are not just tap water.
They have soaps and shampoos in them.
So for this next experiment,
let's try mixing in a little
bath soap to the water
and seeing how that changes things up.
Making a little bathtub martini (laughs).
If it's not dirty yet, it will be.
Voila!
OK, our wires are live, here we go.
(funky pop music)
And you can see things
are a little bit brighter.
Oh yeah, that light is
quite a bit brighter.
I wouldn't say it's full bright.
Those are the wires touching
and that's disconnected.
I'd say we're maybe 50
to 75% of the power,
but that's quite enough, that's
enough to give you a tingle,
if you're sitting in a bathtub
with a high current
device like a hairdryer.
So yeah, bath soap and water
definitely increases the conductivity.
Interesting.
So that was pretty cool.
We saw exactly what house
power does in soapy water,
so I think its time to level
it up now to high voltage.
Now you guys remember this thing,
this is a big, old bulky
neon sign transformer.
It pumps out 12,000 volts of electricity,
but it's current limited to 30 milli amps.
These are the kind of things,
that used to power those big neon signs,
that you see around the city.
Now in contrast, if you ever get out
to a fast food restaurant,
or any kind of business for that matter,
you'll probably see a neon sign like this.
These are still powered by
a neon sign transformer,
but because of newer technology,
they can deliver the same power
at a fraction of the weight.
Now I want to give a shout
out to my friend, Jerome,
he's the one that gave me this neon sign.
Unfortunately, it's
broken, so there's probably
not much use for it, except
for the power pack on the back.
Now, to salvage a precious
power pack like this,
all we have to do is
disconnect it from the sign,
clip the wires as far up as we can go
and then strip the cable back
to expose the small wire inside.
Now, the voltage we are using
out of our house power was 120 volts.
In contrast, these are 10 to 12,000 volts,
exponentially higher and
that's why high voltage signs
have such a thick casing
of rubber around them.
So for this last experiment today,
I wanna demonstrate the power
of high voltage electricity.
I've cleaned and dried
this glass completely,
'cause we're gonna go back
to using distilled water,
which theoretically is
non-conductive, right.
So how will high voltage electricity
work with distilled water?
We're about to find out.
Now, there are a couple
of really important things
to understand about high
voltage electricity.
Number one, it's so powerful,
it can actually jump through the air.
A normal electric
circuit, you have to touch
the wires together, but
not with high voltage.
High voltage can jump the gap
and form its own electrical bridge,
which means flimsy little gloves like this
aren't gonna save you, so
even if you're wearing gloves,
high voltage electricity can
still surge through your body.
Now luckily 30 milli amps isn't enough
to stop your heart theoretically,
but we never really
wanna take that chance,
so whenever you're dealing
with high voltage electricity,
a good rule of thumb is to
put one hand behind your back
and operate everything
else with the other hand.
We wanna avoid the electricity
crossing through our heart
as much as possible.
High voltage electricity
versus distilled water.
Let's power it up and see what happens.
I'm actually gonna put the tip of this one
down into the water first
and then we'll try this second
one and see what happens.
Woah, look at that!
Not only does distilled
water conduct electricity,
but the electricity
actually jumps to the water,
before it even makes contact.
Look at this.
When I start bringing
this second one down,
you'll start hearing it buzzing
(buzzing)
and if I go a little bit further,
it's like little, purple lightning bolts
jumping down to the water.
That's so cool!
If we go right into the water,
it completely disappears,
but I can still feel this thing buzzing.
Bring it out slowly.
Oh wow, did you see the
water get stuck to that?
That is bizarre, that is really cool.
I was not expecting that.
So this isn't something
I was expecting to see,
but as I start pulling the
electrodes out of the water,
it seems like the water
connects to the electricity,
at least it gets about
three-quarters of an inch
off the surface and then
drops back down into the dish.
Look at this, I can do both at once.
That is crazy.
It feels like I'm pulling
the surface of the water up.
Wow, what happens if I
bring them closer together?
Wow!
So apparently the water
is even more conductive
than the air, because if
I hold the two together
close to the surface of the water,
it will choose to go through the water,
rather than through the air.
That's very interesting
and these little water bridges,
that we're making are nuts.
It doesn't seem to matter where
I place the electrode in the dish,
the electrical pattern
doesn't change much.
OK, bring them far apart, close together,
it's exactly the same.
(funky pop music and buzzing)
I see like tinges of green in there.
That's kinda cool, huh?
Let me do that again.
OK, we're probably having too much fun,
we'd better stop (laughs).
Very, very cool experiment, guys
and very unexpected with
the water sucking up
onto that high voltage electricity.
Of course, the real question is
what does distilled water taste like
after it's been electrified?
Mm, it's very, very warm.
I think there's bits of
wire floating in there.
Mmm, it's very interesting.
It's like warm on the
top, cold on the bottom,
it tastes electric.
So let's summarize what we've
just learned here today.
There's nothing in distilled
water, except water itself,
and by nature, it won't
conduct electricity.
So we tried using tap water next and found
that it will conduct a
small amount of electricity.
We tried adding bath soap and
stirring it into the water
and found that it made a
substantial difference.
And finally we went back
to using distilled water
and high voltage
electricity, where we found
that even though the
water's non-conductive,
if the voltage is high enough,
it'll still jump through it.
Thanks for joining me for
this set of experiments today
and a big shout out to my friend, Jerome,
for donating his neon
sign to our cause today.
I'll be looking for you
guys in the next video.
Talk to you then.
(buzzing)
Electric.
(funky pop music)